all right your name is george little
jungle boy from blackstone
that's a blood game that's my hood now
yeah
blood gang out of l.a he's filming where
i grew up at
my dad here o.g from there
before me so originally
uh with everything gangbanging i grew up
where like the [ __ ] originated from
up in louisiana for a little bit and
then we moved out there by you know by
white castle were the vice lords
disciples out of chicago out there in
new orleans they got the gangster
disciples and [ __ ] so you moved from new
orleans
to chicago for a little bit
and that's when i was all out here when
i was born out here but i was raised in
new orleans chicago and then you came
back to l.a yeah i came out here when i
was about
i want to say eight
and
uh that's what my um adopted slash
foster mom move moved us out here to
cali where was your mom
my mom she was uh
she had to tell you the truth i don't
know
i always thought my foster mother was my
mama until um
my big sister came looking for him
so besides that i didn't know
but
[ __ ]
was what was your childhood like how
would you describe it
my childhood [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man she was uh
she was an attic and [ __ ] you feel me i
don't really know i just know i had to
have heart surgery another baby because
i had a hole in my heart and blew my
[ __ ] out
so that's why they took me from her
and then
other than that i grew up in the jungles
i know you hear it called the asian j so
i was back and forth from the jungles to
the antichrist parts you feel me
you joined the gang and what age i
joined the gang when i was 10.
i don't know i joined the gang when i
was 10
uh took my five man
goddamn
um i got with four of them the fifth one
i ain't gonna lie i got knocked out by
the g homie you feel me
but it's all fun though
cause you know after that you smoke your
blood drink do what you do so it's gucci
you feel me but
after 10 or mommas went from hustling
doing what it do something happen
see most people don't know about life
the jungles back in the days you
probably hear about it where
when people tried to come on the block
especially my block the g-walk palm will
you police won't even come down there
you couldn't even come through the block
like hey call that kill century like
wherever you go if you know your way
around the jungles you'll get trapped
it's like a big ass maze you ever been
there it's right up in the hills yeah so
we got alleyways cuts
oh mama started out as a runner boy for
the g homie
doing what it do carrying my year still
you know doing what to do with the dope
as i got older you feel me
i got i want to say what
because i went with six at nine and then
i want to say around like 12.
she said i was too wild so i had went
back in the system
and then i had went to um juvenile hall
got into a juvenile hall i got booted
out because of my medical
and uh
so when i got booted out i went home
never went back to juvenile hall
but uh mamas i went to hustling i know
you could see my orange and [ __ ]
so it's on my arms my chest from
hustling to gangbanging filming [ __ ] i
got wiki
i got kidnapped and he was like tortured
threw in the trunk i woke up i was in
the trunk bleeding all this [ __ ]
my big sister tay
oh my god you got a lot of cuts is that
is that what all the cuts are from yeah
on your on your torso yeah my arms just
on my arms my stomach
little [ __ ] after that
dude oh mama so i woke up in the trunk
when i woke up in the trunk i wouldn't
even know
you feel me like you look the [ __ ] up on
internet [ __ ] that's what this is from
right here
you got shot in the head
is one of the things if you look at it i
can show you
it went through the back right here
that's where they shot me
you got shot in the forehead no i got
shot in the back of the here
and it came out that's why i got a plate
in the front three right in the back
yeah you know the splinters the the
center piece that little split [ __ ]
where your brain is it parts or whatever
the difference having to do yeah that's
it when a dude fired a bullet it split
so basically the [ __ ] being old it saved
my life it's not one wouldn't really
call it a misfire but you know anything
about guns and ammunition like every
once in a round like with a 2 2 3 or 227
a bullet is split when they flip
like piece of it come off
so [ __ ] that [ __ ] split it went
through boom boom oh mama's lightning
gonna lie i thought the [ __ ] misfired i
didn't even know i was hit
and my girl she didn't even know once i
caught that we asked my sister when i
caught up oh mama dad called my chick
she came and got me but she just came
and got the car she didn't even know i
was in the trunk you feel me
so my mamas get to six hours she popped
the trunk boom i'm out yadda yadda i
just tell her like they was torturing
the [ __ ] you see my hands they broke my
fingers and [ __ ]
oh mama's cut out my attendance
show [ __ ] oh mama i deal with that it
did i want to say
i want to say like
what
around that time i was like 18
so from there was there any damage any
brain damage from that i had tbi i was
uh partially paralyzed from the waist
down
i had a
calculator they wanted to give me a [ __ ]
bag
but i
couldn't because
uh i guess when the dude hit me down
here one of the blades the [ __ ] it tore
my um
is it the lower intestines or the big
intestines that you [ __ ] with
so that nick that so they were saying
that if they didn't do the surgery like
like the feces would be leasing and
leaking into my stomach but what they
did was they went in there sodie and
like still to this day
like i want to say for like the
i want to say for like the first year i
couldn't eat like no hard foods
oh i thought that was an earbuds i
couldn't eat no hard foods so like for
the first year i was eating oatmeal i
couldn't eat no peanut butter and i
could barely eat oatmeal but like
anything that would get me constipated
or make me push i couldn't eat because i
should have tear my insides up so like
to this day i got a big ass like you
know like the sterile sponges and the
packing like all around my intestines
they got it locked in and sewed up in it
so like it won't move or bust because it
should still [ __ ] to this day
so you've done prison time yeah i did uh
14 years in the pm
i had got into a uh i was about to get
to
show a couple more
only said a couple months later
uh
i would take care of some [ __ ]
uh making a deal
and the police came and pulled up in the
hood on the block
and um i got into a shootout with him
that was the second time i got shot in
the head i got hit inside right here
oh my god shot in the in the head twice
yeah i was trying to hit twice one by
the migos and one by the police
and when i was shot in the head the
second time my mama because they said
they did it because when they came up i
was belligerent they said i was
intoxicated
and uh i was armed and dangerous
so i'm like if i'm arming dangerous i
should have came to the house with the
swat
they didn't cut to the house with swat
or none and like i was saying over there
in the jungles
everybody over there knew my pops
you feel me because he was like the
[ __ ] that i made sure the block was
good he did what it do you feel me
all the youngest looked up to him he was
like one of them cool ass og's big mud
bomb your dad was in the gang as well
yeah my dad is from 20s
well my dad my original dad my
biological dad
i don't know that [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
from well me i got a me and my older
sister we got the same dad
but like it's gonna get into a whole
cold twist it's gonna get into a whole
cold twist hulk twist
so
me and my sister the one i'm talking
about that got the same dad
around when all this [ __ ] happened when
i got locked up shot in the head and
they raided the house and everything on
the block
saying that um i was involved in a
police officer shooting
and a couple of sheriffs was killed and
the detectives and yadda yadda
they didn't have no proof no none other
[ __ ] they had was a phone call
and my case really got dismissed because
at the time i had dreads and they said
that the dude that did it didn't have
dress the [ __ ] had braids
but it wasn't enough evidence
so i went i fought my case for two years
and then i ended up being 14
with 85
but within two years process while i'm
in the pen
i don't know if my ambition should tell
you but my sister that me me and her got
the same dad
one of his sons is a sheriff
so
why i'm in jail
in the county jail
if you ask anybody about the county jail
the only way you can get in your shell
is if the police could uh if the police
unlock your [ __ ] from the tower
so while i'm in there when i first go in
they tell me they're going k-12 k-12 is
like uh
it's not pc but it's uh it's basically
protective custody because i had a
police officer in my family so they was
like until they get cleared i'm like i
ain't got no police in my family [ __ ]
talking about
wrong one they was like you got a
brother named marvin polly your dad's
george pilot i'm like what the [ __ ] him
like what the [ __ ] like i ain't never
met that [ __ ] artist [ __ ] like it was
real [ __ ] i know what the [ __ ] and they
was like nah bro you got this dude
so mamas
while i'm in there i want to say
once i get out of k12 i'm in a game
module probably like two months
it's about like two in the morning my
cell get cracked
and when my cell get cracked i'm asleep
but the door is cow it didn't make that
loud ass pop noise so i kind of woke up
but i didn't and when i didn't do what i
was supposed to do oh mama's had a dual
hand around my neck i got sliced from
here all the way around before they
could get you right here mama's hopped
up did my [ __ ]
walked out the room while she was
leaking they said it looked like a
slaughterhouse my wrong blood was
everywhere
[ __ ]
and they tried to give me an ad charge
because the [ __ ] that sliced me up i
killed them
but at the same time the district
attorney told me that it will show the
fence
i was single cell because of the uh uh
um my standards of my case and [ __ ]
and then so they wanted me i had to be a
gang module but they wanted me to where
i moved around and everything you feel
me and i go um like how you say
basically on my program get my phone
calls canteen
but the [ __ ] was weird like the way
everything was going so when that [ __ ]
happened and i came out to sale the
police came up on me i'm tripping on
them because ain't no way in hell
somebody could just pop my door like
that's a steel door like you if you want
to get out that [ __ ] from the inside
like if you big enough and you with the
funks you kick that [ __ ] off the hinges
but other than that
like that [ __ ] ain't opening so they
were saying like it was computer
malfunctionish and that yada yada
whatever the [ __ ]
so
i want to say
three weeks after that i go to court
the judge asked me um what was the
situation about the uh murder myself
i don't know like you ain't gotta know
shelley what was going on was you high
i'm like man my door was popped while i
was asleep somebody tried to kill me i'm
like that came from a sheriff you feel
me the judge is like nah nah you
paranoid with your whoop
miss me with that [ __ ]
so when i uh
when i get back because we was going to
um ccb right down here downtown so when
we get back to the county jail on mamas
that night after i said that
um i'm in the sale on mama's
i'm sitting in my cell
and i'm posting i'm making my spread i
eating [ __ ]
and while i'm in there on mamas my shell
get popped they tell me step outside i
step outside the door boom they tell me
to come to the corridor i come to the
courtroom because in the corner they got
like a b and c wing so when i come out
there big guys black dude come get me
cussed me up like what the [ __ ] i'm
going i'm like man it's like two three
in the morning the [ __ ] going on they
take me in the rec room they handcuffed
me to the thing
oh mama's a big black dude there [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my life started well and i'm
boom boom [ __ ] broke my jaw boom boom i
had two broken ribs and [ __ ] dislocated
my shoulder and came to find out
that um
the [ __ ] was my brother
it was my dad yeah all [ __ ] to the
side it was my dad's oldest son the
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up came in there said i
was um i put a rabbit a rat a bad name
on our family's last name and y'all
i'm like [ __ ] i don't even know you i
don't even know none of your family
you feel me like what the [ __ ] is you on
and they were like well wolfie will walk
and this and that
so
uh mamas i ended up i woke up in the
hospital face swollen yada yada
so i want to say
um it's 2008 i looked that [ __ ] up on
the internet 2008 on mamas i go to court
i want to say i want to say it was a
fourth if it's hard if you look it up on
the internet 2008 that shit's still on
there i'm the [ __ ] that was shot for
the third time not in the air no more
but that's when i was hit in the face
oh mama's inside the car a lot of people
try to kill you huh you've had a lot of
people try to kill you no that's because
they tried well that yeah is i want to
say it's the way [ __ ]
i ain't gonna say it was the way i was
raised including your own family huh
including your own family yeah oh mama
but that's just on my dad's side like on
my mind's side ain't nobody like on my
mind's side it's all love but my dad
like the [ __ ] just like them
weird like my auntie and them they've
been trying to talk to me since she
passed away
you feel me and link up with me nate day
but it's just like everybody see
anything good they don't see that one
side to the [ __ ] i went through on the
inside you feel me
and like my sister in there and they
tell me all the time like stay away from
yada yada cause they fake woof
but it's just principles like
oh mama so when i was in court then
fools shot me because they said i tried
to escape
and like how you gonna escape they said
cause i punched the glass window
oh mama's a judge when he started when
she started talking about my time i
ain't expected to say that much time
that soon
so when i went there they was talking
about giving me 365 years
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
i'm like y'all tripping i'm like what
the [ __ ] am i facing again
uh they were like um double homicide
uh uh police officer they were like uh
it was double homicide police officer
and they gave me like 11 10 murders
so i was like yeah i like y'all rabbit
ass mine i got me [ __ ] up that's how
and uh my [ __ ] back pushed the window
and the officer
like he came inside to take and i don't
know if you can see you see like two
little black spots on my side yeah
the [ __ ] he cared i was so hyped up he
came held the taser to me for like five
minutes i didn't go down i kept punching
the window broke it out
and on everything when i tried to climb
out the window with it um you know how
it blocks the uh court the the tape from
the judge when i tried to climb out that
[ __ ] mama's the deputy he done my [ __ ]
but that [ __ ] went through and i don't
know who i could
i should knock out my wisdom tooth and
[ __ ]
so [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
and i was in there that's the crazy part
they thought i was high on drugs in
there but i wasn't i was just mad
i've never seen anybody with as many
scars as you i i that's what a lot of
people sure don't know if you can see it
here but there's there's a hundred knife
wounds on your torso yeah they're
everybody telling me i look like and
they like i'm a real african black
panther you know the evil one
oh mamas
but like that [ __ ] yeah this [ __ ] man a
lot of people don't know man all this
[ __ ] though all this [ __ ] right here
right here
this [ __ ] came from the kidnapper like
[ __ ] like this right here
these deep ones right here
this one that's a gunshot wound
this one is from getting stabbed up in
the pen how far did you go to school
me yeah oh i graduated i went to 12th
grade you did
i graduated school do you regret joining
a gang huh do you regret joining a gang
do i reject going in joining the game
at the end of the day nah cause you're
told me like i ain't gonna say like it
taught me who i am but it taught me more
about being a man and you know what i'm
saying walking the streets like i tell
these young cats it's gangbanging [ __ ]
it's not a joke it's not played it's a
lifestyle no matter where you go
[ __ ] if [ __ ] know you they know you
so you feel me it was just what
halloween oh mama's halloween me my
daughter
and uh my um guy nieces we driving boom
boom
oh mamas [ __ ] seeing me they knew me
knew the car they lit that [ __ ] up on
halloween this year shot my car up boom
i got out what to do
yeah i got shot in the nuts on halloween
my sister taylor was laughing at me
because when they came my [ __ ] was
cocked up like this
oh and everything but she was tripping
about that [ __ ] she was like [ __ ] how's
you still up walking and eating inside
the head the face now [ __ ] shot in the
nuts
so all together what i say gunshot
wounds if you want to go through girl
shot story
i want to say all together
with the
three facial
it'll be
what 28 28 times i was shot
so like it was me and like [ __ ] don't
understand that and there's about 100 or
more stab wounds on you oh the stab ones
i want to say that's about like i want
to say like 175 yeah oh mama and then i
got up on my back too we're like [ __ ]
you think it's karma
karma from doing what i was doing when i
was younger yeah
uh how many people you think you killed
yeah you want me to speak on that on
camera yeah i do
yeah
no we're not naming names oh okay we're
just rough number rough number
uh
don't say before i went to jail
rough number
between 10 if it ain't
including the guy in prison too right
and then and then there's a guy yeah the
dude before i went to jail about 10 15
then uh
in jail in the county
only one in the county because the [ __ ]
he tried to slice my [ __ ] yeah and then
in the pen
i had broken cat neck because we got
into a melee
and uh the [ __ ]
oh mama's [ __ ] was wicked [ __ ] i don't
know if you see this right here
but
you can see it yeah yeah so
while we squabbing on mamas we squabbing
a dude run up i dunk low and i came bam
slap his ass but when i came up on
mama's we had got into a riot with the
woods so when i came up her mama that
[ __ ] had like a little foil
but i want to say like that big a little
pocket banger and he stuck me in my [ __ ]
all the way here
i ain't even know the [ __ ] had that
[ __ ] that much [ __ ] on mama boom bam
getting with it
with the [ __ ] hanging in my [ __ ] and all
that again with it boom bear
pick the [ __ ] up slam him on his neck
oh mamas i turn around get with his
shimo
and uh the homies they looking at me all
funny and [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] y'all
staring that [ __ ] like these [ __ ]
running up
we doing our [ __ ] boom boom
next thing i know the humming like bro
you got a knife sticking out so here i'm
like let's stop playing i turn around
and get off boom bam and when i turn
around and get off
the homie he screamed and it's a real
ass [ __ ] like this the damon
heat pass out i thought [ __ ] homie's
like bro you got a knife so when i
reached to pull this [ __ ] out
oh mama that's when they shot me with
the mini 14 in my leg
you know what the mini 14 is it's like
the okay it's the
okay you ever see you ever hear people
say we don't get no warning they don't
get no warning shots so it's a mini 14
it's the big ass it's the rifle that
shoot the two two three
rounds so i got hit in the leg with the
two two three the mini 14.
so from here to here it's all still
right
so like my bone was reconfigured and
everything
but the whole time i'm standing up
with squabbling yada yada
and i wouldn't go down so the little
tiny lieutenant nolan he came out
and
the homies they surrounded me because i
wouldn't get down i was like out of and
i ain't gonna say i was zombied out but
when i get mad i just nut up like it's
like all red it's it's done for
so while we was um doing that lieutenant
lonely and he came up on the yard it was
like power man i need you to get down
like man y'all [ __ ] shot me
you feel me i'm like i got this [ __ ] in
my head i need to take it out i'm like i
can't feel my face
they like what the [ __ ] i'm like yeah i
was going to take it out next thing i
know i get hit like this [ __ ] bro
y'all trying to kill me here too and
like i just left the county now y'all
need trying to take me on a pen like
what the [ __ ] going on
so
oh mama nolan he'd do the [ __ ] a1 he'd
take off like they got it to where they
could hog tight with the strap on the
ankle so he take that off and he put the
little whatever they want to call a
tourniquet on my leg to stop the
bleeding because the [ __ ] hit the artery
and all that
they lay me down hell of acne i come
back go to the hole yada yada
i get out
but i kind of scared some [ __ ]
one thing that i didn't leave out like
this should be i don't know if you know
about the [ __ ] that's going on with
sheriff bacca
you know sheriff baca right how he got
fired and [ __ ] jail time and all that
so i'm under one of those cases where
the [ __ ] uh
they investigated him under me
for one of the shits when i was in the
county jail
so apparently after all that [ __ ] i want
to say
about the third
time i had my cell got popped oh mamas
um they moved me to uh
not pc but they moved me up to the
medical floor because i kept having
seizures
i guess whatever the [ __ ] did
yeah all that all the bullets through
your brain and nice yeah you're gonna
have seizures yes i kept having seizures
and [ __ ] so they moved me to the medical
floor so i'm in a medical flight
thinking everything's gonna be gravy
they'll let you call home yada yada so
while i'm up there and they start doing
weird [ __ ] like the shares all of them
was cool except for this one mexican so
i want to say like
i want to say for like the first
five months
i swear to you not probably like once a
week i was getting down with the shares
oh mama's getting tased it'll be one
taser two tasers swipe the white
you feel me so they got to the point to
where and i gonna lie i learned my
lesson too after that
because uh they ended up getting the
biggest spending dude off my uh floor
but i got with them boom boom and then
this one one chef named marietta he came
up while i was taking off on his partner
they was tasing me and i wasn't going
down so that [ __ ] he actually put me to
sleep
like um like i ain't never been put to
sleep before like do you believe in
karma
yeah
do i think that was karma no do you
believe in karma yeah i believe in karma
to the foolish on mamas i believe in
caramel karma's a [ __ ]
like to the foot but you're still you're
still standing huh you're still standing
though yeah and that's the thing
everybody tell me like oh mama they say
your book is written before your ass
come out your mama coochie so you feel
me before you come on your story
everything from the beginning to the end
is already ready you got nine lines huh
you got nine lives yeah i said that my
nieces call me wolverine and [ __ ]
so
i [ __ ] man i wouldn't say i want to say
like technically nine
nine lies because she
like just just on the streets i didn't
died a couple times
and in the pen i'm talking about [ __ ]
it's to the point where they got a
federal investigation not just on the
[ __ ] that happened in the county jail
but in the king from them not giving me
my medical medication
i just man all type of [ __ ] the [ __ ]
trying to kill me in the pen my shell
getting popped in the pen i'm waking up
after they get down [ __ ] in the pen
getting stabbed
all type of [ __ ] you have any regrets in
your life any regrets
uh i say the only regret i say
that i have
like all but to the side the only grit
that i would have is basically
going to the pen
because i wasn't out there for my
nephews and [ __ ] he filmed my show yeah
me i got a daughter
oh mama i got a daughter and i didn't
even know about her so what
i'm going to say like
my 10th year here yeah you spent half
your life in prison yeah monk i went in
when i was young
what 18
18 yeah i went into county jail 18
and from 18 i didn't get out until this
is 20 22 20. i didn't get out into 2021
so yeah ashford
that was like what 2078
2007
so 2007 to 2021. george what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
the most important lesson like mamas
never take family for grading you feel
me
and one thing i'll never do i see all
this [ __ ] down here everything i ain't
never doing no drugs i didn't show this
[ __ ] i just seen the game wars over it
the the blood over it everything like
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] vicious i didn't
cook this [ __ ]
rocked it hate that for me but i can't
[ __ ] with it like these [ __ ] [ __ ] with
they want to smoke it and
you ever played around with drugs i
smoke weed that's it like everything
goes
i can't do it like i know me like like i
know me like i like [ __ ] i like weed i
like eating food so at the end of the
day i know me
i got like how you say like the
addictive uh personality yeah you feel
me so
i feel that if i start showing and i
like it too much it ain't gonna be no
stopping no rehab so before i do that
like i'm gonna distance myself from it
like oh mama that's why i won't sell
nothing that i use if i smoke weed so i
won't sell it if i'm selling something
it's gonna be crisp cavities some [ __ ]
like that you feel me cause i know i
ain't gonna touch that [ __ ] so there was
one time i went to a g homie and i
should pour cigarette the [ __ ] gave me
a cigarette man that [ __ ] was laced with
cern
i must have ran from crenshaw what was
that crenshaw stopper the crenshawn king
to king and buckingham to the block
[ __ ] nikki
because of the water like they said i
took off down the street while i'm
running i'm coming out of my clothes
yeah
that pc will mess you up yeah man mama i
was like what the [ __ ] it did my dad i
ain't know what the [ __ ] it was my dad
when i came out he's seeing my eyes and
i'm like man what the [ __ ] i'm going up
on him they like what the [ __ ] are you
smoking with my smoke no shame all i did
was get a cigarette from big hug
he was like who the [ __ ] i told him he
was like yeah and that [ __ ]
big homie and pops they got out and they
took they homie fade boom bear pops
knocked him out
and uh my mama she got out there though
this my mama's you probably heard from
my sister my mama crazy my mama got out
there like that hoes foul we'll do
drugging my baby with the wool and my
dad like yeah they didn't do [ __ ] it was
a [ __ ] you feel me that's why i got out
with him but the homegirls because i ran
on the block they was like cut for my
ass and trying to grab my [ __ ] and [ __ ]
while i [ __ ] up and i was recording
this [ __ ]
so when everything pops took me the
house gave me some milk put me in the
shower that [ __ ] came down after that i
said never again
like i get homies all the time like if
i'm out there selling crystal or some
[ __ ] they'd be like bro you
not even close bro i sell this [ __ ] get
the money boom bam yeah yeah anything
else
yadda yadda [ __ ] asked me that's all
the time and on mama and i was just
disciplined like that because i started
selling dope when i was young before i
even came out here
you feel me
so
i saw dublin at 10 years old yeah i was
selling dope at young gay oh mama's
rocking back and that's all i said i
started off as an air boy but for me i
just you know
cook the [ __ ] cut it up and go drop it
off oh mama's my g homie give me my
little thing for the week you feel me i
go get my dollars plus my money for
cooking and cutting it up and running it
around
so [ __ ] when i was doing that at 10
i had my little moolah my mama tell you
it didn't matter you feel me she'll go
up in the refrigerator my little sister
she done found [ __ ] plenty of times she
had gone there a big ass bag of hot
cheetos you think it's hot cheetos
oh mamas it's a bundles of ones fries
tins all up in the bag mama going in the
freezer she see the ice cream boxes full
of stacks of money and [ __ ]
and that's what my pot he not my
biological father but he was my dad like
the [ __ ] like he raised me he put me on
he feel me put me out there so he had me
on everything he said me down talk to me
like what the [ __ ] is all this and like
ah and like you know i'm kidding like
i'm tired like for real for real i want
to wear feelers and all this other [ __ ]
no more
and [ __ ] like that he was like man i
just be safe with you
it was like letting you know what's
going on in my household though i'm like
for sure say less
what do you see for your future huh what
are you you just got out of prison a few
years ago oh me yeah i got out of prison
in 2021
2021 oh okay mom just like
last year
um
in march
what do you see for your future what do
you want to do what do i see from my
future
um any chance you can be back in prison
again hell no i ain't gonna lie i didn't
told my family i ain't going back to
jail they're gonna have to kill me
uh swear to god i am not going back to
jail they're gonna have to really pop me
because
that's uh i
or certainly not my family didn't think
i was gonna make it off
when i say the police was trying to kill
me bro like that nigga's just trying to
kill me like that's just like sad like
it's it's to the point where the homies
is coming up to me like maybe you know
the police they gotta uh
they call that [ __ ] like a jug they put
a jug down on like [ __ ] out here to
call it green light but they were sound
like i was a little jug you feel me like
oh mamas if it was an issue they're
sitting the m.a towards my way because
it was already facts out that for one
they had me labeled as a cop killer for
two they had me labeled that i had to
green light on me from my brother so it
was already the goal to take me out for
the police
so that [ __ ] was just fun and game and
in the pen i don't know if you heard
about the [ __ ]
for like the gang members are [ __ ] you
ever heard of green wall the police they
got their little gang in there so mama's
in here police you say one thing's
stupid that's only at salinas valley but
uh mama's when i was at salinas valley
that's where i got into the ride at
and after i got shot i was in the hole i
was in the little um infirmary [ __ ] then
i went to the hole while i'm in there
mama i say some i didn't even say it was
some weird [ __ ] it was just smart mouth
[ __ ] but the sheriff he asked me was i
hungry i said what the [ __ ] it look like
hell yeah i'm hungry i'm like cantina
for another week like hell yeah i'm
hungry they stay into the month
like i want my breakfast check hey like
yo [ __ ] ass they got a woo boo and i'm
like yo [ __ ] ass could just give me the
tray [ __ ] and shut it up it's too early
hey like oh i got you paulie you're like
[ __ ] you want to get out i'm like [ __ ]
give my training when i'm done needing
we can get in this whatever [ __ ] i'm
hungry
i'm just thinking i'm talking [ __ ] he
talking [ __ ] cause they say that [ __ ]
all the time
so after they come pick up the trays i'm
sitting there doing my morning workout
man this [ __ ] come tap my door like
pilot um sergeant want to see i'm like
what they're like the surgeon want to
see
all right what
yeah you want me to pull you out
and you can pull me out instead of
walking to the office right across this
[ __ ] take me in the back towards the
west name like what the [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] that i talk [ __ ] to he's like you
still want to get out
i'm like what the [ __ ] i look around
like [ __ ] that's a joke y'all about to
give me an ad charge what the [ __ ]
they're like nah [ __ ] we gonna get in
he took off his arm his little best [ __ ]
his utility thing his [ __ ]
and got out yeah i don't know if they
thought he's gonna win my ass or what
god don't know bam drop this [ __ ]
homeboy rush me the rest of this um
little ceo boom bam
[ __ ] they ass up
but on mamas i want to say after like
fourth person
i turned around and all i heard was
and they could hear me with that
villager
my [ __ ] with lights out
oh wow i don't know if you can see at
the top right here another little
yeah
that's what i said split my [ __ ] i feel
that i still feel that [ __ ] to the day
on everything cause they got like keloid
kilo skin on it and everything like that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up like oh mamas i woke
up in my room
but i ain't doing no snitching i ain't
snitching on police and then obama when
um they came and found me before the
fool laughed it was like man you did
that [ __ ] like a g bro you ain't screen
coughing or uh whoopi well well i'm like
you know i did like a g but y'all need
some [ __ ] bro you knocked me out with
a baton my [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] it was
like all right when you want to get out
i'm like nah i ain't getting down again
[ __ ] because you ain't gonna hit me
with the baton again man like you got
the game [ __ ] up bro but the homies
are saying like bro you did your [ __ ]
you did your [ __ ] i'm like yeah that
[ __ ] knocked me out he got the melee
though like that [ __ ] he got the inner
function of it all right george thank
you so much for sharing your story man
for show boy i appreciate it man stay
safe
yes
you